you got married you got engaged you got
married right there we're still we're
still married yes still solid brother
the only thing scarier than losing you
right now would be to marry you
you're here because someone in your
relationship has issued an ultimatum i
want a ring on this finger one partner
is ready to get married and the other
isn't sure
so
kobe when you issue the ultimatum and
you guys wind up on this show together
i'm sure you knew that you guys would be
partnering with other people to figure
out your relationships but did you guys
know you would be actually trying to
date other people
okay so when it goes to the dating part
yes um of course i think that was kind
of the whole concept check and make sure
the right we were with the right person
to begin with
that's kind of the whole concept and
the part that we didn't really fully uh
get a good grasp of before prior to the
show was actually sleeping with the
other person in the same bed
so that's what kind of threw everyone
for a loop and really shook things up
for the i think all six uh couples
so did you guys feel jealousy set in
immediately when you're watching your
you know significant other on dates i
saw six dudes eyes hit my one girl yeah
it was long it was like it's on dude it
took me i think i really didn't feel
jealous until watching it back and
seeing his conversations like with
lauren specifically i was like thank god
she laughed
yeah
madeline i mean everybody was
like going after colby colby was
everybody's first pick it seemed like in
those first few days
did you have any idea that that's the
way it was going while you were there or
was that a surprise once you watched it
yeah i kind of did the girls kind of
talked and it was like all really like
oh look always kind of nice yeah i was
like yeah okay
but i just i felt i mean i think colby
gave me a lot of confidence going into
this he was so like
gung-ho on me i think i just kind of was
on a little bit of a high horse where i
just let things slide and was just
enjoying my experience of it so
yeah and you seem to have a pretty good
connection with randall like right off
the bat what was it about randall that
that made you say this is a dude i could
spend some time with but before she says
anything i knew that was going to be her
pick from the beginning as soon as you
walked in there i was like and she's
going to pick him
how did you know
that's just her type of man clean cut
very put together um
he's i'm not saying like i'm not saying
that for myself i'm just saying the way
he looked presented himself carried
himself next to his woman
um i just had a feeling like that was
going to be her pick from from the
get-go
yeah i like that he was he's very kind
of calm wasn't too like
in our first conversations he was laid
back cool
um smart and
i just we just had a good vibe and i
mean it's connection it just kind of
happens
yeah so once you guys
you know were able to watch back what it
was like those three weeks where you're
you were both with other people
what were the conversations that you
guys had about that
well so we watched them individually
which i think was good but also we
talked things out so much we were like
so transparent with each other because
we were like nothing can come out on tv
that we haven't talked about for sure
that we kind of like over we told each
other so much more than what was even
shown that it wasn't neither one of us i
think we're thrown through a loop or a
surprise but i mean it i think it's just
a little a little bit of a hit to
actually see the visuals yeah that's
definitely one area we do not struggle
in as far as a couple is communication
at this point yeah yeah
right but it's that was definitely
something that helped us out throughout
the show was just communicating being
transparent making sure that um we've
really indulged on this whole experience
and uh getting the full thing you know
full experience out of it
yeah let's let's touch on communication
because there were definitely moments
during
the show during arguments that you know
where both of you guys would get up and
walk away what did you learn about how
to communicate from this experience i
would say definitely um we need to have
more private discussions before we have
a full discussion with friends and
family
um to make sure we're on the same page
of understanding for
too many outside views that really don't
know what's going on in the inside um
influence or sway um the way we respond
to react
i think that's the biggest thing that i
learned or took from it
um i think also being where we are now
we're in an entirely different spot now
than we were you know at that point it
was are we gonna be together are we not
like i'm trying to figure out
like if there's a sign that i should get
rid of him right so when anything goes
wrong i'm like i'm fighting for myself
as we're now we're fighting for each
other um
so that's that's the biggest difference
so a big point later on in the season is
colby you hooking up with somebody
and then
it's the the dinner what you said i did
that for
for you so you would realize exactly
um
where what's your take on that now i
know at that moment you said i don't
have any regrets but looking back i need
to go oh yeah no no i can't regret
saying that
yeah i know for sure um i i regret it to
you know the point of which i don't ever
want to blame madeline for my own
decision that i made clearly
um it was for me and it was to make sure
i did get the full experience not just
from the emotional connection that i had
um
within the experience i was in
but i had to venture out to get the
physical because i didn't get that with
april so that was my choice to leave and
go outside at this whole thing to um
make sure that
i got the full experience that i was
supposed to get
yeah
madeline was it that
that sort of realization that he had
that
that allowed you to come back and say
like you know what i do want to be a
part of this relationship that's now
that he's had that that perspective
shift uh i can move forward with this
that was that was all that i needed
really i wasn't so mad at him for
kissing someone else i mean how could i
be i was i kissed randall you know and
it was more just about he was so upset
with me for kissing randall and like
couldn't and that i mean i think it was
more of a coping thing than like him
getting what he needed out of it but it
was like all i needed for him to say was
hey i did this i want to be honest with
you about it and i want to move forward
that was it instead of i did it for you
you know that just didn't make sense to
me so yeah when i heard that i was like
oh god oh no
i was also like oh god oh god
yeah yeah yeah uh but then you guys
you know by the end you're you got
married you got engaged you got married
right there we're still we're still
married yeah still solid brother and not
only that but we got a little bun in the
oven
35 weeks pregnant right now whoa
yeah
congratulations you guys
thank you so much oh my god are you
going to name the baby ultimatum no
okay good don't no
no no we do have a name picked up but
we're not going to reveal that yet